where is brad now his office is on the
other end of the house and so
uh we have this system here intercom
system
no oh my god
wait a second you ring that bell and
brad comes running
well there he is
[Music]
hi brad how are you wait listen
be honest with me are you not getting
resentful
of george he's not doing any housework i
do some no you don't poor bread i mean
i mean enough with the george is the
star around there he can [ __ ] clean
up a bathroom
flashback 1986 were first getting
together as a committed couple
george's toilets were filthy dirty he
never did toilets
all his life so i've been doing the
toilets for 35 years howard
i mean here you are you're one of
hollywood's power couples i mean this
idea that george is sitting there
like a the king the grand pub because
he's an actor
ringing a bell and he's constantly
working
everything you said is 100 accurate
however
i don't like george to do the housework
because he's lousy at it
the only thing george can do is talk
right
i know so there you go yes so you are
taking care of
the vacuum bedroom you're kidding i mean
george i hope you
treat this man like the prince that he
is
no no he doesn't because then like
the banana is not quite ripe enough
properly put out
in enough days and so he's still
conventions about it
you are kidding me so if george's banana
isn't ripe he holds you
responsible for it i mean what a
pampered man this guy george is
but he insists on doing because he he
says i don't do it properly
he's very possessive controlling and
dictatorial you're calling him names
because he's busy taking care of you
this is insanity brad brad i mean this
is crazy
you know what george really does
basically he just reads the new york
times every day and watches msnbc
that's so honest i mean it is ridiculous
howard if i could jump in for a second i
got to tell you so we send this
kit out for people so that they sound
better on the air and it has to be put
together
so brad did everything you know we
didn't see george
we set up last week and brad's like
sweating working his ass off
and then george comes and sits down
right he's the king he sits down
and then brad gets out of the way
because that's what he likes to do
george's nickname is he calls him
bradder
something wasn't working and we know not
to ask george
so you just hear he bellows brother
bradder yeah they need to talk to you
and he comes running in and the only way
i could say
he he runs in almost like edith bunker
you know what i mean
he plays with everything and he fixes it
and then he goes away and then he yells
for bradder again it's very funny
if i get one of those bells for beth do
you think my marriage would be over
is that a bad idea
you